joe is with us joe is in milwaukee hi
joe welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you for taking a call i appreciate
it it's a first-time caller
um i'm 45 years old and since 2015
i've made it a priority to invest and
i've been doing self-investment i've
not received any guidance and i think
i'm doing everything right
and i'm trying to figure out whether i
should now invest to get
a professional financial advisor
so in 2015 i started with 200 000
and currently i have about 1.7 million
with 900 000 in a brokerage account
well done sir well done well the same
question then applies how much of this
did you inherit
zero okay so uh you are not a uh
you're not an evil rich person who is a
trust fund baby you're just an evil rich
person who saved all his money up
yeah so so i did a thousand dollars a
month
every single month since 2015 and that
went into
uh into a vanguard account i'm so proud
of you okay listen
there's no arguing that if you just keep
doing what you
keep doing you're gonna have a whole lot
of money agreed
correct yeah so how old are you 45
and you told me that i'm sorry and there
is um
you said there's two million dollars now
right no 1.7 one point
total okay there's some there's some so
when you're 52
if that's sitting in a s p 500
when you're 52 on average that's going
to be
3.2 when you're 59
on average it's going to be about 7
million that's if you don't add anything
and you just left it sitting in an s p
500
okay because at 12 it'll double every
seven years
uh at temp at 10 it'll double every
seven years so
s p 500 has averaged more than that now
uh
so then the only question is what would
you get
with a financial advisor because you're
it's not like you have to have it to win
it's a predetermined fact if you just
don't drive the car off the road you're
going to be okay
right yeah and i guess you know the
number grew
so much and you know when it was a
smaller number you know i paid the one
and a half percent for an etf and
it's um you know do with that number
going
the only reason i would pay the one
percent for management is if it gained
me more
than one percent above what i could have
done by myself
so i i feel comfortable with my plan but
it's relatively passive it's
um i'm confident in the market uh i
don't need this money for the next five
years so here's what i would do
your account but they just may need to
have their fingers on the pulse of it
being a touch more active here's what i
would do uh
get on get online at daverams.com click
on smartvesture it'll drop down a list
of the guys in your area gals in your
area we recommend
go meet with three of them pick one
and give them a half million dollars to
manage and let's run a control test for
three years
against your against what you do and
then if they can make you more than they
cost you
for three years then maybe you move some
more over there
so i you know i have met with people in
the past and they kind of tell me to do
what i'm doing
it's in those times of the emergencies
is the financial advisor going to be
proactive and say hey joe i want you to
sell well i want to
buy this or listen they might they might
but a smart vester pro is going to tell
you to hold
just hold if it's my guys because that's
what i'm going to do
when the market dove in in march you
know what i did
nothing and you know what right now i'm
really glad
yeah because it recovered in 57 days
yeah no that's uh and during that time i
i i blocked and yeah
you know we had covered relief and i
didn't pay my mortgage but
i bought a thousand dollars worth of uh
mutual funds that what do you own your
mortgage
uh 235. you need to pay that off today
so even at uh whatever you know three
and a half percent
okay but i'm making more on the market
no you're not
you need to pay your mortgage off dude
you have no idea what it's going to do
inside your brain and inside your spirit
when you don't have any debt
if it was such a good idea to borrow
three and a half percent you would have
already borrowed a million dollars at
three and a half but that
that made you perceive risk a little 200
000 didn't
so i if i'm you i'm cleaning up your
mortgage i'd sit down with somebody
interview them what you're looking for
is something with the heart
of a teacher the heart of a teacher and
um i've got one of our smart mr pros
that is in my corner and i can call him
and talk to him if i want to if i need
if i'm wondering about something if i
want to run a scenario out on something
uh he doesn't have to talk me off the
ledge only things are getting bad but
rachel you and winston meet with the
smartvista pro and you're rachel cruz
that's right well these people they do
this stuff day in and day out but
again joe i mean because he has what his
stuff in like a vanguard account what
did he say yeah he's got an s p 500 yep
so again you're doing fine joe if that's
what you would continue to do
fine but i think i think running the
controlled experiment that would be
interesting to say hey let's put
this other you know 300 000 whatever it
is
in the market and watch it and see what
what a financial advisor does with it
versus just a traditional vanguard yeah
i think what you're missing is some
teaching
and you're missing some input at key
times when you want some input
you don't have anybody bounce this off
of it's a little bit
uh it's a little bit lonely a weird kind
of lonely but it's a little bit lonely
the way you're doing it
and uh so i've got these people in my
corner and you know chris hogan will sit
down in here
at a commercial break and we'll talk
about something or anthony talking to me
about buying a house the other day
so we you know we're just got we got
people to bounce our ideas off of and
you know even though we know the answer
too but it just helps to have somebody
kind of work it and wrestle it wrestle
the problem with
when people like this that are in the
investing world day in and day out again
they eat live and breathe this they're
watching
it constantly they're gonna have a good
pulse on what's going on
i mean you can read health food
magazines and articles all day long
and really be healthy in your eating and
really be in good shape but a
nutritionist could probably teach you
something
right that's a great analogy it's that
kind of thing you probably could get a
leg up you know
you get you know get a you know get some
information you didn't have some
motivation you didn't have
uh but it's not to say joe that you're
like a loser and the only way you're
gonna make it
is with a smartphone it's quite the
opposite you're going to do just fine
if you just keep doing what you're doing
i outlined it for you you're going to do
just fine
but i would get a smart vester pro in my
corner to teach you
and make you think about things and give
you somebody to kind of wrestle ideas
with
but they don't need to be somebody that
just takes over and
and just says well i'm smart and you're
not and i'm going to go to prove to you
that i can beat
what you're doing well that no that's
not what we're talking about here we're
talking about him
or her explaining to you we're gonna you
do these things with your managed
account
and if if they meet projections and
historical data
you sh we should outperform your s p 500
which you can do by the way lots of
people do it my portfolio outperforms
the s p 500 and i still buy some
vanguard
s p 500 i still buy some vanguard and
another one too but i mean
s p 500 is just kind of a place to a
safe predictable place to park money
and it is what you said it's a passive
choice
because you're not having to actively
try to find something and move something
that's beating it
but there you know over half the funds
do not beat the s
p 500 so you can't just buy funds
blindly and beat it
but you can find you can buy funds that
have a track record of beating it
watch them manage them and beat it my
portfolio outperforms the s p
pretty considerably about a point and a
half uh overall year in and year out
and it's nothing really rocket science
about it i'm just picking funds that
have a history of doing that
and watching to make sure they do it
yeah and i think too knowing that
investing is for long term so even joe
being 45
i think some people want like some
fascinating stuff and it's interesting
and it's intriguing you know
not him usually the boring but i'm just
saying for the listener though but
usually the boring stuff over a long
period of time
is much more profitable yes because it's
predictable you know what's happening
and that's what that's him he was that
guy his stuff is not sexy at all yep
and by his own but coming out of his own
mouth he said that it's just steady
and it was a thousand other guys said a
thousand dollars a month for
all this time that's how i did that and
you just you freaking get out of debt
and he's not paying a freaking car
payment you know or two car payments and
sallie mae's not got her own bedroom in
his house
when you don't have any payments you can
get rich that's these people we're
talking to this is real people here
we don't set these calls up they're just
calling